acts 30. act 30. yeah  um it's been too long what's the deal  with Netflix  I had to get into it but in terms of  acting can we be serious right here can  I be honestly I'm proud of what  Christian Bale has done okay because he  listened to everything I told him oh and  he and Daniel day would get into these  crazy wrestling matches never fist  fights because I don't allow that in my  class but they would get upset with each  other yeah what was the story about when  you were coaching Daniel Day-Lewis for  the my left foot thing I said it's not  about your foot  what is it about  yeah okay yeah and he said what do I act  with and what did I say what what your  heart Daniel yeah wow yeah yeah and  that's a lesson for everybody here guys  leave with your heart yeah right wow  yeah that's what I came here to say